okay I see you oh no this one in
particular this is a weightlifting mark
why is there Christmas music okay where
are you guys I gotta find you wait I'm
coming
I got you hey my character model is oh
my god those guys are [ __ ] there we
go I got you okay okay all right
here's how you do you click one you
press one to bust out you just click
okay and that's the game so if you get
strong you can go fight you know how you
got beat up to death like you could go
spider but you know I got mark yeah so
people just like fight all the time
you're good job Gabriel Gabriel what
happened to my arms yeah you're in fight
mode you're in fight mode oh you want to
go you want to go I'm coming I'm coming
I'm not very fast here at God here we go
oh yeah incoming baby incoming oh yeah
where are my friends
wait how do we sprint you can't this if
you want to get faster you got to get on
at red where are you just finding my
that treadmills some by the treadmills
there's a lot of treadmills so you just
keep running I then you
the entire game yeah all right yeah yeah
it's going down I'm gonna team up with
you again cool yes so what happens is
random people random people will be
called into the brawl you have to my
streams have an issues guys one second
oh yeah roblox is very CPU intensive by
the way I don't know why it is
ridiculously CPU intensive so when you
get clipped when you get called in just
fight to the death
oh wait wait you're in you're in the
fight for you wait you're in the fight
LM waiting oh [ __ ] Oh Bob you got it you
got it I believe in your heart help me
I can't I'm not in there your knowledge
let's part wait I'm here with you let's
fight the big guy yeah going fight mode
and the star climb is down wait wait
help here I'll protect you Oh Bob I'll
beat him away foam [ __ ] I went super
saiyan I don't know what happened I
would super save didn't last long I
guess if you do weightlifting long
enough you'll get a combo or something
cuz I went super saiyan mode I swear to
God okay I died you got second place Bob
oh [ __ ] yeah I don't think I can run
this game why not sorry is roblox too
intensive for your favorite baby I've
gone ultra interesting turn the graphics
down or something isn't on like high
graphics yeah are there graphic settings
in roblox I have no idea oh [ __ ] I am
[ __ ] get Marky I believe in you come
see me are you seeing this [ __ ] you're
going you're actually super saiyan right
now alright then I know I'm getting so
big dude dude I can see myself growing
have my speed is a 15 point oh six mark
oh [ __ ]
your speed starts at fourteen you're
really so you're really going for speed
I'm speeding it up I want to be the
fastest little Oh
[ __ ] you can go I'm gonna run
this one out I'm glad that everyone
screams the same that's really Pleasant
[Laughter]
Broly did you died I'm the brawl is
really big yeah yeah it'll happen like
that uh-huh
I'm thicker than you take that nerd yeah
nerd yeah nerd hey Bob you got third in
the brolic that's right wait so what
came in and stomped the guy who killed
everyone else
so how many hours do you have in
weightlifting work uh you know 13,000
I'm here dad hey son how you running
good job you're gonna be fast some day
you're gonna be big like your papa
why are you so far back on the treadmill
no I like to live on the edge I like the
scare and the fear of almost falling off
your head is it growing in size with the
rest of you yeah no you know you're the
brain don't get no bigger I don't I keep
trying to exercise that's why the Giants
oh my god mark are you gonna in the
brawl no I'm running I'm at nine I just
crossed 19 I want to get so fast I want
to be a lifty boy do you have to be a
certain strength maybe I don't know I
honestly have to because there are small
bench presses I would think that you'd
be able to start bench pressing right
away tell me you can't run the best Oh
mark I got beast oh you need at least
2,000 strength to enter big boy beat
sorry for everyone watching I'm just not
gonna be able to do roadblocks until I
figure out what in the world is
conflicting because something is majorly
conflicting there I'm gonna find
something else to play in the meantime
oh come on guys come on Wade just bust
that a old laptop it's just roblox come
on why would roblox run like a turd like
I don't looks like a computer virus when
you download it I highly doubt it's
optimized to be much more than that dude
ohand really this game 100 million
people okay are we great we want to try
a different game yeah maybe try
different stuff there's a tower defense
game that's super fun
L'Occitane offense okay yeah well
obviously do you not like this game for
some reason other than it not working
other than the fact that I've had to
restart my stream eight times no it's
great
so let's try another game and see if it
runs better before we give up on roblox
completely okay all right so I don't
know about you guys but I've been
playing tower defense games since like
the original Starcraft
I love tower defense for some reason you
know if I would call Starcraft tower
defense no no like the custom maps of
StarCraft that had tower defense in it
yeah but this one is very much like most
tower defense games I'm not great at it
but I did just start playing it you you
have your basic centuries in the
beginning so you guys just have the
pistol dude in the bottom left so the
way that I work wait what bottom line
it's just there's just no picture of it
what the hell yeah so you'll have that
I'm gonna pick easy vote for easy cuz I
don't think we could do anything else
since troop not equipped what oh you
don't have any money let you'll get
money you should just get money right
now so can you place it now no it's this
troop not equipped wait at least one
what on my hotbar there's nothing there
what yes that's not right okay all right
maybe we need to get out and get back in
and I break this somehow well we're both
bound to break things on roblox it seems
oh yeah you've got nothing well that's
weird okay let's let's back out this
guy's skin is a nightmare
holy [ __ ] what the hell happened
oh wait you can't see guys you can't see
the guy the game wasn't showing which
one which butthole do they come out of
and which one do they go into and don't
you know you don't have to worry about
until if the game actually starts vote
on easy all right I got the first one
[ __ ] so yeah I don't know how much you
guys actually liked our defense really
I'm here for this how long have I been
muted what have I been doing with my
life that Blizzard game that blue
Starcraft did we do Starcraft the while
back what what Starcraft tower defense
mode is it not with you guys are you
just saying that because I meant you
start
real thing we played I don't know it was
not I played that with someone there's
like a Starcraft and I'm as a mod yeah
ever but alright are you saying that
just because because I mentioned
Starcraft tower-defense do you not
remember me mentioning that no I don't
what what the [ __ ] what's over here man
I've been very busy
later you met you're messing with us
right this one kind of crazy ass bit I'm
pretty sure this is about it's not I why
generally do not hear you mention it mmm
I don't believe I'm really confused
I don't believe you at all we have a
thousand dollars I haven't spent you you
can upgrade your characters also you
click on them and then there's an
upgrade button can you like move them
you have to sell them selling them I
don't think yeah I see you guys just
like spam the beginning okay alright
yeah well that's cuz that's where they
spawned man I get it I just didn't
really want our defense get it is like a
limit of how many things you can put in
a certain radius there is I'm learning
okay I'm learning I mean there's there
still is oh my god somebody has a sniper
what me baby it's me it's me how do you
like that yeah sniper on the grassy
knoll is that guy's head floating like a
foot in his office body yeah that's
really weird
very disturbing person hey look at the
movement I'm doing guys wow really good
there Bobby really found that storm away
but you're in a corner in camp and those
snipers are crushing it I know right I
have no idea I've got my chorus of of
snipers up here raining Hellfire down
upon thee oh these are ghosts there
there are some with hidden so that's why
it's important to upgrade seeing it said
who do the hidden ones dead
[Music]
BAM characters here what what its
efficiency you win at our defense
complain funny sound your complaints
stop complaining every time I make a
comment you guys think I'm trying to
make a joke or complain what are you
making a comment yeah what's wrong with
you Jesus
be normal Hades on his back : yes it's a
picture of Flying Pig Peppa Pig on the
Flying Pig yeah that's what are these
they're question mark zombies what
they're going to yeah when they die they
spawn a random look man I love towered
like this game I like if you can play in
first person
oh hell yeah Island Peppa Pig Hades easy
there's 35 any miniscule little gap you
can just wedge a thing this man who's
gonna storm the games with this many
Gunners like coming down the way some of
these guys that aren't like right by the
entrance don't even get to do anything
anymore
alright a little chance but then my
snipers gonna take him out a little bit
maybe we needed something more than easy
what a dynamic gameplay dude cool I like
roblox okay it's it's cool because it's
it's a bunch of minigames I didn't know
that about robla I thought it was a game
for kids I did literally think it was
just a Minecraft like yeah you gotta do
like I thought I was just the exact same
thing I didn't understand it had this
dynamic gameplay in there yeah and
there's like more than just this there's
ha and it's all free like most of its
free but it's like it's all free which
is really weird oh it's boss boy not
shoot him bought okay well shoot him
bought oh oh he has a lot of lights
oh yes guys slow boss behind him oh he's
not dying soon enough he's gonna die
soon enough
oh you guys are worried over everything
it's where I stop worrying you guys know
worried over everything you worry guys
we're always worrying about worried
everything everything is always worried
you have one man back here to hold the
line no no my snipers have great range
they shoot long and hard how hard this
hard bam boom pow that's how hard this
shoot
all right you convinced me it does have
a weird like difficulty curve after a
while are you guys upgrading or your
dudes yes yeah I've got one guy up front
I've been upgrading rather than buying
new ones so I've got three helmet guys
over here and I'm about that another
helmet guy right here good it's a helmet
guy
helmet guy yeah excellent good good palm
down good I said calm down my excellent
good excellent
I don't allows I don't to tarnish my
perfect record is your record perfect
yeah totally we didn't just lose to get
your ass back in here yeah wait your
fault wait your fault it's your fault
well I'm glad that it encounters a loss
I cannot place more than 15 units well
I've hit the maximum boys so you haven't
been or high or level three row okay
upgrade which you can't just spam I'm
spamming it I don't have that much money
because of how many units I play smart
that's the problem we've identified the
problem
gonna lose like anything's gonna go
wrong we buy it we could uh huh here
comes another slow boss hopefully
doesn't get through he's not as slow as
I would have hoped yeah don't worry my
snipers will take care of this
you have your snipers not set to the
fire at the strongest boss no they're
not they're set to fire at first I'll
put strongest on a few of them frontline
will be strongest oh don't worry these
guys have it I'm pretty sure it's
upgrade him oh yeah the hidden boss
that's about it don't worry when they
come back in range yeah yeah they'll
come back and range of my snipers don't
even bother placing more my snipers got
them guys going to worry about don't
worry about it it's got it we've got me
not worrying about it don't worry about
it everything seems fine everything is
fine why would you worry about it good
well that's why I said everything seems
fine
good cuz it is good good great I'm glad
I'm a Morgul an excellent haven't been
taken care of because they were on ah
they were on strong you made me set them
the strongest holy [ __ ] what is
happening to this guy oh yeah that's
that's not okay mark I don't like it
that was all your fault okay fine
well I'm pretty sure that was entirely
well we got coins I have a hundred and
fifteen yeah yeah actually what I really
want is a demo man where you went went
down the same alley we always wind up
going the wrong way
that's the versus service that's the
versus service that's what I'm saying
mark oh how is marking a level up in I
didn't level up because I was already
close to the next level I'm doing stuff
do you like okay wait did you buy any
more creatures i but I have a soldier
and I've got a dude not too
I could spend robot
I could spend Robox to get oh [ __ ] no
I've left it we're okay we're next one
over here here we go okay not gonna be
here not that one yeah all right yeah
wave you got a good weight though so
deceptive because I brought up the the
micro transaction menu and there's a big
leave below it when there's here and I
was like I almost be out of closest I
would like to leave Micro transit well
this level 26 guys should walk us
through this hopefully maybe now what
happened to the level 16 person well
there's probably outside staring it was
level 133 purple lunar 133 get a life
get a life there'd get a life is it this
I feel good about this one guys I didn't
even see what map we're doing but I feel
good I think considering how quickly
maybe we should spread our guys out
maybe we should take advantage of the
full length of all right I'll build up
I'm gonna this is my area right yeah
it's my little area I'll fill this box
with my dudes yeah I'm you know I'm
actually gonna keep going on the sniper
route I feel like there's some
overarching strategy that I feel good
about you know cuz I want to be like the
coverage of long distance over a wide
area you know what I mean I think that's
what I'm gonna do but I'm gonna spread
them out I'm gonna place them here
hither and thither I'll be sniper man is
what I'm saying are you guys money
though if I've got dudes at the
beginning y'all are in the same money
some of those yeah we are you stupid
I like you're building your sniper on
top of the building that's awesome yeah
it's pretty cool right yeah they never
see it coming
dead brains everywhere oh you can just
hold space well now I can be obnoxious
everywhere all the time look where I can
put my guy I'm up you just gotta climb
up how do I climb come over here and
[Music]
there we go got our sniper Oh get him
boy all right well can you take back the
insult I feel really hurt by it you
really smarted that one up mark I give
you wait does this even work can it even
reach anybody is this radius range what
does it show you his ranges well the
range is like way above the plane I
don't know who's actually okay it has a
useless sniper but he looks good simply
like in a circle and not a sphere
pattern because that would that would
suck yeah that would very I like how the
guy came up here to dance to tell you it
can reach that's good for guys that's
where you left
I'm not gonna give you multiple laps a
big hole mama you such a big hole mama
hey my mom doesn't let me use her credit
card for roblox if you could please
donate to my paypal so I can buy roblox
cards on Amazon that I will give you the
robots content and you're looking for
bobert you hooked on roblox content
probably I'm a 100% roblox streamer all
the time wait it's it's not only a
fantastic game in itself it's also the
best version of every other game that's
ever existed yeah yeah exactly so fight
me it is everything that you'd ever want
in a fight I just agreed No thank you
you win you screw you yeah
dang yeah I'll just go throw this out
there I don't think that other guy is
actually placing anything unless they're
saving up I bet there's they're saving
it oh no he placed this he placed this
oh [ __ ] he did whatever this is this
turret thing it looks like an engineer a
level 1 inch all the centuries like
random pot bodies probably makes all of
my units useless and meaningless
yeah awesome yeah come on sentry turret
get him Wow oh my god what [ __ ] no he
was low on health that's that's what
that was he was low on health yeah he's
got a spaceman we're not bad guys we're
not bad all right he was always saying
things in chat it's better than mini
gunner then that means so little time I
think anything could be better than a
minigun mini gunner you freaking scrub
soldiers get expensive dub cred yes they
do
everything gets expensive to upgrade
dummy you freaking idiot I'm sorry I
didn't realize it was Mark it wasn't me
I'm sorry I don't know it's like a tag
team effort
yeah well takes two to bring you down
yeah I said you're a hard person to
fight I'm really happy with the area I
picked I'm really contributing a lot to
the efforts look when when things go
down you're really gonna it's it's good
at your you're gonna you you you you
[Music]
like the guys in the middle like they're
you spamming them instead of upgrading
them they're not shooting around each
other they just need hidden detection
that's all they need rather than more of
them what are you stupid
who among us is the the roblox pro here
and I've been playing with you yeah I
did Bob I did ask a valid question why
don't you try to answer
I thought you were crying just like I
would see me with a game all day you
were just like fraud mark sounds like
Soulja Boy's all those use make me crank
all over me okay come on quick quick Bob
why don't you contribute you know what I
am contributing you see all this jumping
I'm doing is very distracting yes it is
actually who's this who's this
flamethrower guy and what's he doing in
my turf
I don't think Super Soaker man's
following the rules Superman
the flamethrower kind of looks like a
Super Soaker with orange juice coming
out of it and II just got up great
markers this year man no I don't even
have them yes flamethrower you'd called
it wait he's trying to make some rent
IRL purchases maybe he's century man -
it's mine Wade dude I think mark put him
up to it
I got ya just why Oh CaptainSparklez
rated me why would that Nash hole I was
good hey Jordan how are you doing it's
been a while good to see you are you
still working out you gettin swoll why
do you sound like you owe em money hey
come on
can you please just give me a few more
weeks I just need a little more time
I've been playing a lot of roadblocks
that other knows markiplier the YouTube
content creator known around the world
is completely broke after investing all
of his money in roblox yeah I invested
I did lose many games if only this money
translated to skill I'm doing my bluish
hey can I get your family friendly
stream coming in roblox is family
friendly isn't it should narrated this
nonsense
you have no know you're the world's only
mature rated roblox stream I know I bet
there are some roblox like R rated or X
rated servers out there where they have
skins that actually have roblox games
then actually have row boobs I don't
know what's happening but I kind of like
it
oh yeah would crank me wait I'm ready
and I'm done uh-huh this is this good
for you like it is for me super expert
level both our level of skill on this
yeah our level of skill there we go yeah
we got skill yeah it's super expert a
thing on me what the hell is that
the guy shoots Rockets out of them it
was an angry Bob passing by look at how
much I'm contributing wait Bob actually
hang on oh wait no he's dying okay well
I'm sure meeting man yeah
I'm interpreting yeah contribute all
over me yeah I've got some contributions
[Laughter]
if you just take a look at my portfolio
you see why you should invest my money
[Laughter]
the financial advice that you need with
the roblox content that you crave so do
these turrets upgrade they look the same
just curious they upgrade the same at
all you idiot there come this ones next
to each other are completely different
you are different okay that's fair these
two are different you stupid fool you
actual listen from over here they look
van
I was looking for maybe like a different
color as they upgraded or something no
okay stop being stupid for once in your
life I can't help it I was born this way
baby I was born this way like you either
don't like either of you well I thought
that's not it was that a subtle
correction or a positive bit I don't
like anyone here well I'm not gonna give
you any more thank you finance advice
okay because you certainly need my help
with it
wait I'm gonna come over to your house
I'm gonna I'm gonna expose the lies
[Laughter]
coming to your house soldiers
pistol boys oh my god
ow
[Applause]
the way that that a health bar works is
really concerning let's get the game
itself exclaiming yeah did you not hear
when we lost the other round it played
the Curb Your Enthusiasm song no just
playing now that's why I'm getting now
I'm getting the sad violin song well
what the hell is what are we supposed to
do to counter that I mean what were we
supposed to do to counter that no wait
why do I have ten million dollars what
the [ __ ] yeah what no you do not have
ten million I have dreamed a dream come
here and be proof what the wait mark has
10 million robux why give me real bucks
so I can buy Roebuck what is this bucks
I will not spend them on rope rope Rogan
if you're watching me some goddamn dog I
swear I can buy everything you suck so I
can afford a sniper
it's the dev's which one of you in chat
is the devs of roblox and why showing
bias
mark mark are you over here no I'm to
your left
come here look at this guy's skin we're
mining your muscle Myron yeah
frats I have yes I've shown you the
roblox light this is good I'm just
buying everything before this goes away
[Laughter]
$245 I can buy all the dances I can buy
all the dancer from game to game or my
money for individual game not just okay
so there's robux
and then there's in-game currency these
green stuff is like this like the Robox
Munns okay so the money you've got is
just for tower defense in general yes I
think so all that stuff we're right
there are you okay
I'm loving one what does level one do
for me just like mark oh my God look
mark look around yourself I I'm seeing
yeah I don't know what I did train of
psychopaths
I don't what did I do to deserve this
mark we played the Greeley well the
three of us are close together we can
hop into something right now maybe I
feel like get real close to them choose
one and go okay okay I'll follow your
leads they are really following not even
well no idiot Wade come on and know
which two were you don't have [ __ ]
crazy asking what are you crazy
is so dominant mark give up some of your
money pay them to go ahead alright and
I'm currently going in a game game what
yeah me too
oh did the devs put us in a game
together Oh what is this
what what is what is this oh my god for
insane mode cuz there's 27 of us I'm
confused and scared I'm down for this
I'm so down for this yeah let's do this
yeah let's make this happen
yeah
I'm down i'ma put I don't know this
other oh there's there's two there's
what they come out of both those dude
there's 20,000 of us welcome to the mega
mega server yeah this how it's supposed
to be yeah yeah this is the devs getting
us into a custom game this is this is
special I feel special good I feel
confused
nice place why is no one placing okay
well here we go day/night [ __ ] I don't
have any money I placed it my one place
your [ __ ] you goddamn [ __ ] what just
place your [ __ ] sup hands out here to
play you think they came to play yes
mark this is why we can't bring you
anywhere what did I do
I don't know what you did it my house if
this is the best you're gonna bring me
whoa Bob wait bunny oh we have money
what the [ __ ] oh good good this game's
[ __ ] I can't even place anything
anywhere near the thing is there's a
thousand people everywhere click on my
units with all of you people standing
here alright I think I think we're gonna
win I'm feeling pretty good about this
you know I just have a sneaking
suspicion I have so many questions why
what's up I don't know I can't think of
any off the top of my head but they're
there this took an unexpected turn I was
actually enjoying playing this and now
I'm yeah this isn't as fun this is
definitely not as fun it's interesting
experience but not as fun I was actually
kind of like surprised at how much I was
enjoying roblox which makes me feel
dirty inside let's see how far we can
get
I'm gonna guess with unlimited money
pretty far yeah we might just happen to
make I've actually pretty much burned
through most of the money well I will
get all the [ __ ] that's placed all right
I need the farms so that's been getting
us mucho money alright don't worry guys
I placed another unit I feel like I'm
really contributing here you are
believe actual gold cuz I can't hear
anything okay we might actually lose it
be invincible here comes mine tanks I
guess okay my tanks can't do anything to
that that high waves are there on this I
know I'm not a hundred percent sure
alright if everyone could just type it
once on this game how many waves it is
say about uh this is awful so it's fifty
six waves
we're on eleven there's no way we can't
beat that gold Titan that that gold
Titan is impossible I would agree with
your assessment
he's only God sixty eight quadrillion
health
okay I maxed out on units because I
bought so many forms yeah let's start it
yeah let's keep going yeah I like this
oh yeah I can understand what's
happening how about you well do you hear
the gunfire clearly no I don't make it
on fire way there's a lot of gunfire Bob
let me I think Satan escaped from the
underworld in the form of whatever that
sound is yeah not even remotely dead I
think if he gets through we'll still be
okay
thankfully we have these guys with aks
at the door good job guys that was great
we've got negative 8,000 health on the
okay well alright cool good job guys we
pulled it through okay out of all of you
and I'm proud more of myself we almost
beat insane difficulty we were only like
forty three waves off exactly yeah
something tells me that that Titan was
not part of the normal wave routine and
I think the dev just threw that out
there well the surprise surprise we
almost took it down
I also because we were pretty on time
half of the people in that game ended me
$100 so oh good yeah hey
I feel feel nice and rich hey but at
least I've got dances maybe that's
enough roblox for today no no no I think
I think that this many people just
swarming us like ticks on a dog is good
no it's bad this is good stuff
that's what fun gameplay is all about
but you see did you see you see how it
could be great if I get inside you in
this game mark I'm inside you in Hill
[Music]